Nikki Haley's the United States
ambassador to the United Nations she is
in Washington today to host an unusual
outing for the new york-based UN
Security Council the group will meet
with President Trump at the White House
ambassador good morning good morning can
you tell us more everything that we know
so far about the arrest and the
detention of a US citizen and what we
can do about it well I think right now
we're trying to gather information and
of course this is something we never
want to see happen but I do think that
it's North Korea just trying to show
their strength again and what we're
gonna say is it's just not going to work
and these are challenging times but it's
not one where we're not afraid where
we're afraid to make a decision and I
think we're going to handle it properly
and I think we'll have to use China to
do that and what considerations are
there about options well we have to
discuss that and I think that's all part
of the discussions that will have to
take place we always want to get every
citizen out alive and healthy and make
sure that they're being treated properly
and so those are the things we'll start
to work on former New Mexico Governor
has called these detentions as he says
these are used as a bargaining chip do
you agree with that and do you think
negotiations are possible at this point
I think it's absolutely a bargaining
chip I think that's what their
intentions are whether that's the case
or not as something totally different
what we're dealing with is a leader who
is flailing right now and I think what
he's trying to do is show his citizens
that he has muscle whether it's through
his rhetoric or whether it's through his
actions that's what he's trying to do
what we have done is partner with China
and the rest of the international
community to put pressure on him you saw
the Security Council last week condemned
North Korea for their testing I think
you're going to continue to see pressure
on North Korea we have said for quite a
while now that the United States is not
looking for a fight so North Korea
doesn't need to give us a reason to have
won and I think that they're panicking
right now I know the president Trump
spoke with the Chinese President gee
last night what more does China need to
do well I think China is really in good
faith doing quite a bit they are trying
to put pressure on North Korea what
we've said is we want you to put more
pressure on North Korea whether that's
with coal whether that's with oil
whether it's with other sanctions and I
think that they are also talking with
the leaders in North Korea and telling
them that they don't need to do anything
so I think China has been a really great
friend of ours and the way they came
together with us to do the statement
last week showed that we are united
against wanting North Korea to stay away
from doing any sort of nuclear threats I
know that the Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson said last week that the u.s.
is looking to pressure North Korea to
re-engage with us on a different footing
what does that mean they need to stop
misbehaving I mean that's what that
means is they need to re-engage and not
use force to do that not use testing to
do that we don't want to see a nuclear
North Korea what we've said is they need
to not test anymore they don't need to
challenge us with nuclear missiles and
talk about how far they can go and they
don't need to challenge our military
bases in the area so I think right now
we are not going to talk with North
Korea until we start seeing good actions
come from them we think that very clear
which is exactly what they want a
bilateral conversation that's exactly
what they want and we're not going to do
it because until they show that they are
in good faith not going to test and not
use nuclear weapons we're not going to
sit down and appease them by having
talks with them what we will do is
continue to work with China to get that
message to them ambassador Haley thank
you so much for joining us thanks so
much